a new program in Central Florida is
training people to stop potential school
shooters school safety Guardians is what
they're calling them they have the job
now protecting students and teachers on
campuses that do not have their own
school resource officers for sheriff's
deputies a state law passed after the
deadly shooting at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas high school gives districts the
option to earth-2 arm rather certain
teachers school staff or the so called
school safety Garden Guardians Adriana
Diaz is in Bartow Florida that's east of
Tampa where future Guardians are now
being trained
Adriana good morning good morning these
Guardians who are normal people not
officers of the law
they have been here morning until night
training a lot of them told us they're
doing this because they have kids in the
school system whose safety they're
worried about Guardians earn $30,000 a
year starting this fall that's less than
school resource officers and that
difference will allow every school in
this district to have an armed guard
armed with real guns and real bullets
these everyday people like a minister
former teacher and retired police
officer are training to take down a
potential school shooter I'm tired of
hearing teachers having to give their
lives to protect students we're going to
be there to engage you will not have to
we will run to that threat while you
take care of what you need to why
shouldn't that responsibility fall on
law enforcement you're a former law
enforcement officer we need more people
to step up and get into this function of
protecting our children you're a
minister why did you decide to do this
well I have three small children in the
school system my wife is a teacher
[Applause]
I want to make sure that those children
have the safest best quality education
this is a world away from church
absolutely
absolutely change your targets out for
me please candidates for the Guardian
program have to pass background in
psychological checks before an intensive
six-week course that includes firearms
training precision shooting and both
virtual and live active shooter
scenarios only the candidates who score
high enough on tactical and written
tests will be placed in one of Polk
counties 85 elementary schools this fall
Andrew [ __ ] whose daughter meadow was
killed in the parkland shooting has been
involved from the start these kids are
gonna be safe for now from what what I
accomplished and hopefully the rest of
the country is gonna see what we did in
Polk County and they're gonna and we're
gonna lead by example the Polk County
program was created by Sheriff Grady
Judd and school superintendent
Jacqueline Byrd what about parents who
are uncomfortable with more guns on
campus or any guns on campus those
parents need to wake up and understand
this is a new normal this is the last
best chance to save your child
when all the different layers of
security have failed and their job is
simply this to be well trained to react
within seconds to find the active
shooter and kill him graveyard dead
before he can hurt your child with a gun
we're talking about civilians here not
sheriff's deputies or police officers
everybody we hire in this industry
starts out as a civilian
these folks are starting as civilians
but when they finish their training
they're going to be better trained with
more hours and a higher proficiency than
a state certified police officer you see
what's happening around our nation in
our schools you just wonder is it ever
gonna be here in Polk County I know I
have to do something to ensure that as
each parent sends me their child I have
someone there to make sure they're safe
I come from a time era when we didn't
have to worry about guns schools weren't
on lockdown
and things I know have evolved some
parents like a net rising are concerned
when you drop your daughter off for the
first day of school in the fall how are
you gonna feel about the fact that there
is someone carrying a gun they're
probably a little anxious what do you
say to people who say this only brings
guns into schools which is dangerous I
kindly remind them that guns are already
being brought into school and that's
much more dangerous are you prepared to
potentially kill someone if there is a
threat at the end of this training I
believe we will be ready to do it we
have to do to stop that threat yes
despite your background as a minister
I'm human I have to protect my family as
any one does and I'm gonna protect life
the best way that I can the program was
named after Aaron Feist the assistant
football coach at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School who died while
protecting his students his wife is
gonna be here later today to meet the
men and women who are training to be
Guardians in the name of her husband
Adriana Thanks reporting yeah it raises
a lot of interesting questions which is
as they're taking this extensive
training course which is good they may
be faced with the possibility of having
to shoot dead a minor because in many of
these cases these school shootings have
been carried out by boys who were 14 15
you know someone the same ages their own
kids potentially